the crucifixion and resurrection of
Jesus Christ
it is the story that transformed a tiny
group of believers into the world's
largest religion but was the story
really new now a tablet called the
jeselsohn stone named for respected
antiquities collector david jeselsohn
has recently surfaced we don't have
anything like it of such a long
prophetic biblical inscription from that
time on stone the jeselsohn stone
threatens to destroy the claim that
Christ's crucifixion and resurrection
were unique the sensational claim that
made all the headlines was that the
writing on the stone indicates that the
Christian belief in the resurrection of
Jesus wasn't anything new that the
belief that a messiah might die and be
raised after three days already existed
in Judaism before the time of Jesus the
tablet also known as the Gabriel
revelation stone tells an apocalyptic
story much of the wording has eroded but
what remains is a vivid tale of
Jerusalem besieged by armies and a final
battle in which a prince of princes will
come back the Antichrist
but the most interesting passage is line
80 in which the angel Gabriel commands
of Prince of princes to do something
after three days exactly what that
command is no one is sure time has
rendered this passage virtually
unreadable but Hebrew University
professor Israel Canole thinks he knows
the answer
Konoe believes that Gabriel is
commanding the Prince of princes to rise
from the dead after three days so
Gabriel is speaking to this person and
he's telling him commanding him actually
in three days leave resurrect Canole is
perhaps the world's leading expert on
messianic figures from the time of
Christ he is out to prove that the stone
tells the story of the Messiah before
Christ and that Jesus knew of this
Messiah and based his own life on him
canola's interpretation hinges on a
passage in the stone just four words
long most scholars agree that the first
three words are by three days so we can
say this is line 80 we have first the
the words little ossetia mean in three
days this is clear no question about it
but the debate is on the force word the
fourth word has been washed away and
that's where the controversy comes in
according to Israel Canole the last word
has only one possible meaning live to
Canole the angel Gabriel is commanding a
prince of princes by three days live
in ancient Hebrew the word live is
sometimes spelled with four letters pet
Aleph uurgh and hay
but in line 80 on the stone only the
first three letters of the mystery word
are clear if the last letter exists and
turns out to be the letter hei then
canola's translation is correct the word
is live proving that the story of the
resurrection predated Jesus I don't
think you can read the tablet I think
that section where he's seeing in three
days rise is illegible I don't see those
letters there and by the way neither
does anyone else
some scholars believe that the mystery
word can be read not as rise or live but
as raise us up he will raise us up is a
common ancient Hebrew phrase meaning
God's mercy will be granted to all
people if this translation is accurate
the jeselsohn stone is an interesting
find but not a revolutionary artifact